[Music]
there's been a lot of anticipation and
secrecy surrounding Apple's upcoming
release of the iPhone 5 and here's the
latest news last week an Apple employee
left a working prototype of the iPhone 5
in a bar and somebody stole it yeah this
has been big news obviously Apple wants
this prototype back they've already
released an ad to address this situation
we have a copy take a look we're very
excited about the advances we've made
with iPhone 5 but unfortunately someone
out there has stolen one of our
prototypes and will give it back we will
find this person
and redefine the world of genital
torture the current plan is to strap
this lowlife to a tree and feed him or
her a rare African species of
flesh-eating firearms and then we'll
film that person being devoured from the
inside out and then post that video on a
revolutionary new iCloud it's amazing
that in such a short period of time
we've managed to create a digital form
of the Ebola virus that we can inject
into a feeding person's eyes
we are planning things that will make
vlad the impaler
look like mr. Rogers
[Music]
give us back now
[Music]
[Applause]